hey guys what's up i just want to tell
you about my patreon it's called the
honeydew with y'all
and every week i do an episode of the
honeydew
with y'all okay it's five bucks a month
and now
you get the honeydew a day early
ad at no additional cost if you sign up
for a year
you get over a month free that's less
than a cup of coffee y'all you know what
i'm saying
now if you're not subscribed to the
patreon let me show you
what you're missing this is liz perry
liz
she highlights her low lights living
life in a wheelchair
it's like what's some of the most
embarrassing moments you've had in your
wheels oh god
okay my grandfather pushed me off the
curb
in front of cinderella's castle and i
landed on my face
in front of everyone and zoe smith here
zoe smith knew that a guy she liked was
gay
knew he was hiv positive and still
had unprotected sex with them anyway
and is now hiv positive because
that's how that [ __ ] works it was so
hard for him for me to get him to be
into me
that when he wasn't to me i was like
let's not ruin this with like
clinical with aids
and then you got mike frampton here all
i can say about mike frampton is he's a
death janitor a lot of the d
comps uh if they're really bad like if
they're weeks long
you end up [ __ ] the next morning and
smelling decomp in your [ __ ] because
your body
yeah yeah no you smell dead body in your
[ __ ]
yeah and then
you got damn batis dan batisse
all i can say is this dude had a
mind-blowing experience
gordo shot that [ __ ] in the back
of the head and his [ __ ]
face just went all
over me dude holy [ __ ] dude honeydew
with y'all y'all
i'm highlighting the lowlights with
y'all
[Music]
do
[Music]
you